скан центру і мохи ман ок розшукай я все
вирує і про актуально сховатися в Європі
які польський рецепт виходу політика
закордонної пошуку сонячна політика
я чистий але й загальна європейська за
зовнішньої політики і ми мусом вона на і
спливати вдало полів така політика
на актуальні за грози німа нижча
Відповідь крем спину і сучасна
європейську політику у сфері bespeco та
оборони
політики знатну в годину розпізнавати і
за грози тасс знаходять і вирішення проблем
плями голему за грозами в Європі
maemo на уазі ситуацію в Україні
анексію крима агресію в донецьку то
луганську то еньші
на святі та русі та в Україні та ясно
лагідні за країни російські в Україні
найкраща ситуація складно чіпа ділячи це
вигадку Михайла Горбачова чим і знову
стоїмо він опитуванні холодної війни не старше
мовлення більшість склянки bespeco з
правді ясна купа я не вірю повтори не
історії холодно вина була результатом по
справі Європи на сфери спливу двох держав
нині у нас менша сутуація нині edge
якщо не може вивести для співу брати це
діалогу було б фатальними б ми ні ми
нашвидкуруч сталося
і замістив знову про намагалася про уста не
війни на важливі вояка та холодної
випорожнення вони менше ні до чого
доброго не проводив соботович скажи мені
та нехай ми по ви не рубає і все про і
тигони допустить і найголовніше
закласти мої будні з здобутої собі друзів
мабуть ви бачили агресивна політика
така політика екта по-російськи днів
україні єни пропустимо вихідні україни
старшого грудня до лісу буде новий глава
європейського та родеку зайві польська
прем'єр
стр дональд туск на ці акценти в його
європейські політики б розруху і так
ось це треба бар джейн про але так я думаю
відро б ти мобіль shine gloss на крапка
зору нових crying я не гей з завантажуємо я
також чек ще when shes розпізнавати та
ми за грози та конфлікти вузькими європ
дональда туска влада його активно
політика нові ідеї та наступальний
стиль провини боїться викрутив саме так
польші успішно функціонувала 5 гривні
ством туску вин праве україну через
ложки годинник про світ через економічну
щура 2009 року
але питання дастана для нього вив і канви
ікла вінду дасти європейські політики
нові динаміка та c добрий ок для Європи
так для польші та допит якуб вона
міністра дякую вам